este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a das
line das link es una herramienta de
seguridad todo-en-uno que te permite
generar contraseñas seguras almacenar
las guardar tu información personal y de
pago guardar notas de forma segura
proteger tu privacidad todo de forma
rápida y precisa beatas lane puntocom
visual polític s y descárgate lo de
forma totalmente gratuita además usando
el código visual polític s podrás probar
la versión premium totalmente gratis
durante 30 días y luego si decides
continuar con ella tendrás un 10% de
descuento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos áfrica es el continente de los
retos de los grandes retos
[Música]
hablamos de un continente que ha
comenzado a despertar sí pero donde
todavía está todo por hacer desarrollar
una red sanitaria de verdad impulsar la
industria mecanizar la agricultura y por
supuesto responder al enorme reto de
mejorar la educación
[Música]
amigos amigas y echamos la vista atrás
podemos ver que si algo ha caracterizado
a los países que mayor salto económico
han logrado dar en las últimas décadas
ha sido precisamente su empeño por tener
sistemas educativos de mucha calidad
en países como japón corea del sur o
singapur la apuesta por tener sistemas
educativos de primera fue algo que
facilitó su transición económica en
pocos años todos estos países pasaron de
ser pobres economías rudimentarias a
convertirse en potencias económicas de
alto valor añadido
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es exactamente lo mismo que ahora está
ocurriendo con china por supuesto su
éxito se debe a muchísimos factores pero
en todo ese proceso de despegue
económico la educación ha jugado un
papel importantísimo y no es que sea
sólo una cuestión económica sino también
social cultural y política y ahora ahora
le toca el turno al continente africano
atentos colegios que no son colegios
evidentemente situará el áfrica
sub-sahariana al nivel de los países
desarrollados en términos educativos
será una tarea titánica que llevará
décadas ahora bien igual que una caza se
empieza por los cimientos y no por el
tejado desde hace más de tres décadas
todo tipo de organismos públicos y
privados han invertido cientos y cientos
y miles de millones de dólares en
reducir el analfabetismo y mejorar la
escolarización a lo largo y ancho de
todo
el áfrica sub-sahariana sin embargo el
reto es tan grande que aún queda mucho
por hacer fijaos
[Música]
la exclusión que existe en los sistemas
educativos de áfrica es uno de los
mayores problemas a pesar de todos los
esfuerzos realizados más del 20 por
ciento de los niños de entre 6 y 11 años
continúan sin ir a la escuela y si
hablamos de niños con entre 12 y 14 años
la cifra sube a 1 de cada 3
la necesidad que hay en las regiones más
pobres de que los niños se incorporen lo
antes posible al trabajo en el campo y
la dificultad para hacer frente al coste
de la educación son las principales
causas que explican esta situación y es
que veréis aunque en gran parte de
áfrica se ha copiado el modelo de
educación pública gratuita los padres
siguen teniendo que sufragar gastos como
el uniforme los zapatos los libros o el
transporte y claro eso en una región tan
pobre en ocasiones antoja complicado muy
complicado
pero si pensáis que la falta de acceso o
el no poder pagar los gastos es el único
problema de la educación en áfrica
estáis muy pero que muy equivocados el
otro gran reto y tal vez el reto más
importante al que se enfrentan los
sistemas educativos de áfrica tiene que
ver con la malísima calidad docente y
también con el derroche y descontrol en
el uso de los fondos públicos si vale
puede que muchos de vosotros estéis
pensando alberto vamos a ver es lógico
que la calidad de la educación en el
áfrica sub-sahariana no sea la más alta
qué esperas que tengan el nivel del
mighty vale si eso está claro pero aquí
cuando hablamos de mala calidad nos
referimos a cosas como estas
[Música]
en muchos países africanos como es el
caso btr sierra leona es habitual que
existan maestros falsos maestros que
reciben sí y su salario del gobierno
pero que ni enseñan ni trabajan tan solo
en sierra leona desde el año 2009 se han
detectado y eliminado más de seis mil
seis mil maestros falsos de la nómina
del estado
aunque para ser justos esto no es sólo
un problema de áfrica es un problema
frecuente en los países más pobres en
pakistán por ejemplo se llegaron a
detectar más de 8.000 8000 colegios que
recibían fondos del estado fondos
públicos y que en realidad no existían
eran colegios fantasma que a donde iba
el dinero bueno mejor no preguntéis pero
ahí no acaba todo incluso cuando
hablamos de maestros que existen de
verdad que no son fantasmas bueno
digamos que en áfrica lo de no ir a la
escuela lo de saltarse las clases es
cosa de los profesores y no de los
alumnos fijaos
[Música]
en el áfrica sub-sahariana es frecuente
que los profesores no se presenten
regularmente en la escuela para trabajar
algunos estudios determinan que en
países como kenia o nigeria este
absentismo afecta al 15 por ciento de
toda la plantilla pero si esto ya parece
una locura atentos porque por ejemplo en
kenia este porcentaje aumenta hasta casi
el 50 el 50 por ciento si hablamos de
profesores que van al colegio pero que
no entran en las aulas a dar clases
y todo esto por no hablar de que no es
algo infrecuente que muchos maestros que
sí dan clases pues tengan dificultades
para leer o no dominen las matemáticas
básicas incluso aunque sean profesores
de matemáticas si vamos lo que se dice
un desastre en toda regla y es que no no
basta con abrir colegios así no se
soluciona el problema hacen falta más
cosas sin embargo si esperad un momento
porque no todo es tan malo
[Música]
además de los colegios públicos y los
colegios abiertos por las ongs y la
ayuda a la cooperación hay otra
alternativa que durante los últimos años
está ganando mucho peso en la región la
educación privada low cost si si habéis
escuchado bien educación privada y low
cost en la misma frase
amigos de visual política aunque en
buena parte del mundo la educación
privada se considera reservada a las
personas con más ingresos en áfrica esta
barrera se está rompiendo podrá acaso la
educación privada contribuir a superar
los problemas que tienen los sistemas
educativos del continente seguro que esa
pregunta nunca te habías hecho
[Música]
pues para profundizar más en este
fenómeno y saber qué está ocurriendo en
este vídeo nos vamos a centrar en los
ejemplos de dos países muy diferentes
kenia y liberia quien es una de las
estrellas del despegue africano su
economía lleva creciendo desde el año
2013 a una media de más del 5% anual
liberia en cambio sigue siendo uno de
los diez países más pobres del mundo y
está sumido en un montón de problemas
sociales y económicos
pero qué tiene que ver un país tan pobre
como liberia con la educación privada
cómo y por qué un país con esas
características impulsaría un modelo de
educación privada atentos
ah
liberia conscientes del desastre
pues si el gobierno de liberia se ha
dado cuenta de que tiene un problemón de
tal dimensión que les resulta
prácticamente imposible gestionarlo por
ellos mismos tras 14 años de guerra
civil y constantes epidemias la
educación ha quedado en un segundo
tercer o cuarto plano y si a esto le
sumamos una corrupción descontrolada el
fracaso de los servicios públicos está
cantado y claro de una gestión
desastrosa cabe esperar resultados
también desastrosos sin embargo el
gobierno de libería ha decidido romper
la baraja y apostar por una manera
bastante novedosa de lograr que los
pobres tengan acceso a una educación
mejor
[Música]
el responsable de este cambio de
estrategia ha sido ni más ni menos que
la mayor empresa dedicada a la educación
privada low cost en áfrica la bridge
international academy es una empresa
fundada en el año 2008 en kenia por dos
amigos estadounidenses
actualmente la bridge cuenta con más de
600 colegios que ofrecen educación a más
de 120.000 estudiantes pero no es la
única empresa que se dedica a esta
actividad ni muchísimo menos ahí destaca
también la rising academic otra de las
principales empresas de colegios
privados low cost en áfrica
en este caso fundada por emprendedores
británicos y canadienses
[Música]
pero como no podemos hablar de todas las
empresas que están surgiendo nos vamos a
centrar en el caso de british que es la
que es más grande de todas y la primera
pregunta que tenemos que hacernos es
cómo diantres se financia esta empresa
pues a día de hoy consiguen salir
adelante en gran medida con el apoyo de
instituciones como el banco mundial y
con donaciones que hacen grandes
empresarios como por ejemplo es el caso
de mark zuckerberg o bill gates los
fundadores de facebook y microsoft
respectivamente y es que hoy por hoy en
la mayor parte de los casos este tipo de
empresas rentable es lo que se dice
rentables pues no lo son
al menos si no tenemos en cuenta las
donaciones que reciben por ejemplo en el
caso de international en 2016 lograron
facturar con el negocio 16 millones de
dólares pero tuvieron unas pérdidas
operativas de 12 millones es decir que
los costes fueron un 75% más grandes que
los ingresos
pero un momento no penséis que estamos
hablando de algo así como una ong para
nada estas empresas si tienen ánimo de
lucro lo que ocurre es que conciben su
modelo de negocio a largo plazo esperan
que el desarrollo económico que se
empieza a vivir en muchas regiones de
áfrica ces permita alcanzar pronto los
beneficios
y por supuesto mientras tanto reciben el
apoyo de muchísimas donaciones como las
de bill gates que compensan con creces
todas las pérdidas del negocio ojo son
donaciones que en muchos casos reciben
precisamente por tener un plan de
viabilidad es decir por esperar que sea
un proyecto rentable autónomo y
sostenible a medio plazo
porque claro gastar es siempre muy fácil
pero conseguir que un proyecto sea
sostenible por sí mismo eso ya es otra
cosa
la cuestión es que precisamente por este
motivo a pesar de todas esas pérdidas la
empresa continúa con su plan de
expansión gracias a los más de 140
millones de dólares que ha conseguido en
inversiones y donaciones
sorprendido el caso es que en 2016 el
gobierno de liberia un país donde menos
del 40 por ciento de los niños reciben
educación primaria decidió colaborar con
ellos por qué pues porque fijaos cómo
funciona la educación pública en este
país
[Música]
y profesores que no aparecen incluso
siendo pagados por el gobierno no hay
libros la formación es muy floja la
infraestructura de los colegios es
insegura tenemos que hacer algo radical
georg werner ex ministro de educación de
liberia
el caso es que de acuerdo suscrito entre
el gobierno de liberia y la prix
international contempla que esta empresa
opere 93 colegios públicos con nada
menos que 27 mil alumnos el acceso a
estos colegios sigue siendo gratuito el
gobierno paga por los estudiantes se
trata del mayor acuerdo firmado hasta la
fecha entre un gobierno africano y las
empresas de educación privada y ojo
porque el experimento parece estar
siendo todo un éxito en las pruebas de
nivel los estudiantes de los colegios
gestionados por bridge international
logran un resultado mucho muchísimo
mejor que los estudiantes de los
colegios operados por el estado para que
os hagáis una idea en las pruebas de
nivel las diferencias son del 100% es
decir los estudiantes de bridge logran
resultados el doble mejor es que los
estudiantes en colegios bajo el control
del gobierno
pero esperando un momento porque a pesar
de todo no todos los países le están
poniendo las cosas tan fáciles a este
tipo de empresas es por ejemplo el caso
de kenia el país donde nació en la
propia bridge international atentos
[Música]
la desconfianza de kenia no nos
engañemos los colegios privados pueden
suponer toda una amenaza al control
estatal de la educación y eso a muchos
gobiernos no les gusta y por supuesto a
los profesores públicos tampoco eso es
exactamente lo que está ocurriendo en
kenia donde el sindicato nacional de
profesores lleva años realizando una
durísima campaña contra el modelo de
colegios privados low cost supuestamente
porque los profesores que imparten
clases en este tipo de centros no
cuentan con una licencia gubernamental
aunque los resultados académicos sean
mucho mejores no tiene autorización y es
ilegal
wilson sos jones secretario general del
sindicato nacional kenyatta de
profesores sin embargo es cierto que sí
que hay algo de verdad en sus argumentos
la propia empresa lo reconoce
técnicamente no cumplimos la ley pero
del mismo modo hay miles de colegios que
están operando de esta manera
shannon may cofundadora de la bridge
international academy claro
entre otras cosas los programas
educativos no están redactados en el
país ni cumplen la exigencia de los
gobiernos locales sino que son
redactados generalmente en el extranjero
en el caso de bridge el rendimiento
educativo es incluso evaluado por
profesores de harvard que la verdad que
queréis que os diga sin ofender a mí por
lo menos me inspiran más confianza que
los políticos de kenia
por supuesto no todo es tan bonito y en
ocasiones se dan situaciones
desagradables empresas como bridge
international no dejan de ser empresas
con ánimo de lucro y que exigen a los
padres estar al corriente de los pagos
algo que en un lugar como áfrica no
siempre es posible
[Música]
pero sin embargo cuál es la alternativa
colegios públicos donde los profesores
van a clase cuando les da la gana o
donde las clases de matemáticas las
imparten personas que a duras penas
saben multiplicar
[Música]
amigos en el áfrica sub-sahariana los
gobiernos son muy ineficaces a la hora
de prestar servicios públicos y por eso
están surgiendo muchas alternativas en
algunos casos se trata de empresas y en
otros de organizaciones sin ánimo de
lucro lo importante es que estas
iniciativas se están revolucionando la
educación en áfrica
puede ser que invertir en colegios
privados low cost que esperan ganar
dinero sea una de las mejores fórmulas
para contribuir a desarrollar una
educación de calidad en áfrica puede ser
que la inversión sea mejor que la mera
ayuda desinteresada y una última gran
pregunta que seguro os habéis hecho
muchas veces está a salvo tu privacidad
en la red pues cada vez somos más los
que nos preocupamos cuanto de seguro son
nuestros pasos en la red y es normal a
menudo escuchamos noticias sobre todo
tipo de brechas de seguridad que nos
hacen preocuparnos bien pues si buscas
seguridad con das line la encontrarás
das lente protegerá de todo tipo de
amenazas contra tu identidad hay muchos
malos en la red y la mejor manera de
esquivar los es utilizando das le das
link es una herramienta de seguridad
todo-en-uno que incluye un vpn para
todos tus dispositivos de tal forma que
puedas usar redes públicas como la de
los aeropuertos cafeterías de forma
segura y anónima yo siempre lo uso
dust lane también te proporciona el
monitoreo de la dark web que consiste en
escanear la web en busca de datos
personales filtrados o robados alertando
te al instante en caso de que tus datos
personales se encuentren donde no deben
tal forma que puedas tomar medidas
rápidamente es súper útil y ya lo dice
en dicho mejor prevenir que curar y por
supuesto daschle inta ayudará a generar
contraseñas seguras y cada vez que una
web te pide introducir las que ayudará a
rellenar todo de forma rápida y sencilla
es súper cómodo lo mejor de todo es que
das link es totalmente gratuito pero en
caso de que quieras tener acceso a más
servicios quién es una opción premium
pero sabes lo mejor si entras en das
link.com barra visual polític s usando
el código visual polític s tendrás una
prueba de estas opciones premium
totalmente gratis durante 30 días y si
decides continuar con ellas obtendrás un
10% de descuento entra en el link que te
hemos dejado en la descripción y
descárgate estás link de forma gratuita
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]